you know he said he wanted to attack
Iran
this was done by the military given to
me
um I think we can probably get I don't
know what we'll have to see yeah
as president I could have did last year
this is extraordinarily damning this is
going to be uh an exhibit for sure in
the forthcoming either criminal trial of
trump or something that will be
presented by prosecutors at possible
plea negotiations to say look at what we
have we've got you you might be better
off taking a plea now not only is it
abundantly clear that this is part of
the criminality it's also important to
understand that Trump with absolutely no
hesitation whatsoever no qualms No No
Reservations at all regularly lies about
this stuff